everyone in the states is angry at
everyone and there's sides but when you
go out in the world
you don't meet those people
I have to realize that my audience isn't
on [ __ ] Twitter all day the actual
asses and seats the warm bodies
have [ __ ] lives it's the best feeling
when you have a bit that you know the
audience is gonna laugh at and then
think oh that was wrong but it's too
late because you laughed because I'm
right and so like I I write as a defense
attorney
okay I'm gonna take something that would
go against the grain of the audience
find a [ __ ] loophole that makes
perfect sense like a defense attorney
yeah and then
you can't handle the truth
because I accidentally ate a bunch of
gummies when I was cleaning out the
[ __ ] bar before football Sunday and I
thought no this is a must be a special
bag of gummies because you ate a bag of
weed cookies I ate four weights four ten
milligrams what kind of state were you
in well I it was weird because it was
during when I was trying to do sober
October and that's why I was out
cleaning on a Saturday night because I
was sober and I didn't know what to do
with myself I hate myself I'm watching
my podcast
in my head I'm watching what you're
watching and I'm like just shut the [ __ ]
up dude
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine kitten
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People our brilliant guest today is a
comedy great Doug Stanhope himself as
you can probably tell we are in the
world's smallest hotel conference room
Doug Stanhope is about to join us in a
second when we give him the green light
this episode is not for the
claustrophobic
oh well guys sorry uh that we're in this
[ __ ] access room of the executive
Lounge no you're the Superstar came to
you
how did you score in the room at the
last minute when you realized we paid
for it yeah in advance we knew the [ __ ]
up was going to happen that your hotel
room wasn't going to be big enough right
so we got a backup uh but Doug uh you're
one of our favorite Comics it's great to
have you on the show uh tell everybody
how you got into comedy like what what
was it the Droid
nobody nobody really cares absolutely
nobody cares we can we can't believe the
comedy and no one has a good story about
how I thought I was funny and I couldn't
do karaoke and I couldn't do other
things and
so no [ __ ] up child
one of them no not really my pretty tame
childhood I mean I was the problem in my
childhood
other people had a bad time because of
me I was a problem child but not because
of any kind of outside influence
can't blame the parents just didn't yeah
because you've got like a unique style
of Comedy they you've forged your own
path in many ways like how did you get
about doing that how did you start to
create what we know is like Doug
Stanhope style comedy I have no idea
it's been 32 years so
yeah I I didn't start doing this I
wasn't some Prodigy where I had opinions
or something before my time I was 23 and
did masturbation jokes and whatever
titty bars and pornography and we were
talking about this uh me and Hannigan uh
I'm very high by the way and I've been
doing this for the entire tour so the
show you saw last night that's where it
kind of went all right
maybe too high last night like I could
not read the room
people were yelling at me to make jokes
about the queen yesterday for people who
are watching us back it was the day the
queen of the Queens
yeah the funeral part that's not how we
do things in England oh really yeah
we did not just burn the body at the end
we just stuck the queen on a putt just
went all viking and [ __ ]
the idea of a queen is as [ __ ]
Antiquated as a funeral buyer that's a
good point it might as well burn her in
the Town Square on the day of her
funeral
well you know that's what a [ __ ]
funeral is for most people is being
burdened alive but they're dead yeah
burnt dead absolutely yeah yes but
anyways
you ended your show with a joke that
didn't the cause silence and you said I
thought we'd have a moment silence for
the queen and walked off stage did I say
that last night yeah yeah
that is fun it's a great bit of AD lip
I don't remember the end of that show
that's the problem because I'm not a
high guy I've never been a pot guy and I
started playing with it during the
quarantine just Edibles and uh and then
I Did It On Stage just as a tester
coming into the UK in Detroit where I
took it on stage when I started to go
okay if it goes poorly I I'll be at the
end anyway I'll just bail a little early
and it went great and then we ran into
Edibles on the beginning of this tour
and I'm like I'm
so I did like full High day it's the day
we did the have a Word podcast and that
was fun like the whole day I was and so
I was high on stage I'm like I'm getting
high on stage every [ __ ] night which
I never did in my whole career
so last night was the only time I went
maybe too big of a room
are you enjoying the whole way
because I'll be honest with you we all
love an edible here yeah I [ __ ] enjoy
writing I actually enjoyed the process
of writing where like when I had to come
back after 18 months off
I was writing a set by myself high and I
just started writing like long hand like
everything I'm saying and then I get
like a a Heckler I'm writing a Heckler
heckling me and then I'm trashing the
Heckler and I'm laughing my balls off
like this is worth nothing
this is just an imaginary show that I
just wrote out long hand and uh yeah I
like I like the the creativity and uh
it's it's like doing
doing drugs and then doing an art form
which I think stand up is like it's so
much fun the only problem is is like you
alluded to before is when it tips too
far like I remember once well it takes
away some of your skills that you're
you're like I'm watching my brain react
to a Heckler to someone shouting out to
me
bluffing a Segway and I'm watching my
brain watch itself almost like 3D
imaging and I'm just having a completely
different experience on stage where
but then you lose a skill like all right
I heard that guy just scream again mate
go to the queen
how loud is that do I need to address
that and I'm watching my brain process
all the things that are usually on
airplane mode in your comic brain you
know it's happening but I'm watching
that happen it was [ __ ] great
probably not so much for the audience
and Doug you mentioned not doing stand
up for 18 months what was that like
Bliss that's when I realized what I want
to do with my life is absolutely nothing
you you didn't miss it you didn't miss
the bus oh not at all no really no no I
missed none of it that's incredible
because I stopped doing stand-up after
the pandemic I was like this isn't good
for me that like the lifestyle is
killing me you know traveling around and
doing the show I've got another thing
that I really enjoy doing so you really
but but I always thought you I imagined
you would like it would be the thing
you'd miss it like crazy you've been
doing this for 30 years man I know
at some point you go hey I think I've
said everything that I need to say I
don't know how else to repackage this uh
but I did have I had I thrived during
yeah but I I bought that house at that
point it was 15 years I'd lived there
and I didn't know where my [ __ ] was
really and I said a year and a half to
go okay I'm gonna [ __ ] organize the
Tupperware drawer like you just as a 32
years of traveling so you get home maybe
you have a couple months off at best but
you're just like
dump in your bags repacking your bags to
go out again that gave me a sense of
home
that makes a lot of sense man and listen
let's talk about your show a little bit
because one of the things that you talk
about in your in your current show is
how did you come up with trigonometry it
wasn't hard
because when he said the name I'm like
all right it's going to be a play on
words is it trick trick trigonometry I
go that's [ __ ] brilliant and if you
have a brilliant title the album will
follow yeah yeah trigonometry well we
were trying to sort of say to people we
might have controversial conversations
with different people we want it to be
free basically to have whatever
conversation we wanted so it's kind of a
trigger warning in a way like we're
saying this might be offensive yeah
that's why I was wondering why you're
asking me how I started
all right what do you think about the
Jews though
no no but listen like I was I was gonna
ask you because in your show you you've
got a very strong anti-authority
and I'm trying to downplay that now why
why because everyone's got a [ __ ]
opinion and like you have to
balance what's going on with like I used
to be very anti-government until
anti-government like okay you're doing
it wrong like I'm trying to Soft Touch
how to be anti-government and I'm
working on things that again the Edibles
[ __ ] help
create like oh I'm actually thinking
creatively without forcing it because I
have a tour coming up yeah uh but then
you go okay now I have too much
information and I don't [ __ ] know so
I'm going with what I know right now
which is not [ __ ] uh but that's it's not
like everyone's got a [ __ ] opinion
like overnight
and does that make comedy more difficult
the fact that everyone's got an opinion
whereas before like you'd go out and do
some stuff and whatever it may be most
people would be like okay I'm gonna
listen whereas now they're like I I
riffed on that last night above the
whole
there was a construct of what's really
going on if they said there's a or we're
at war with Afghanistan everyone's on
the same page that we're actually at war
with Afghanistan now it's split into
every news is fake news and that's
manipulated and that's slanted and and
you have no idea what the [ __ ] and then
you realize I don't care none of this
affects me yeah there's no truth anymore
is what you're saying that's uh yeah and
I I quote Roseanne Barr she said that to
me
where she
I was doing her podcast and she's got
[ __ ] queuing on Benson she's yeah and
she knows she's mentally ill and she
goes yeah how do we do comedy anymore
when there's no such thing as truth left
and it's that was the most important
thing I heard during quarantine
so how so what is the part for a
comedian now how do you do jokes when
everyone's got their own different
version of reality
well uh talk about the [ __ ] that matters
to you
uh
talk about your life
if you're just talking about your
opinion of what you hear on mainstream
Media or not mainstream media because
you're cooler than that and then you
still get someone else's [ __ ] opinion
yeah maybe you should do something
this is your life yeah well coming back
to my anti-authoritarian question the
reason I was asking you is that like the
comics I grew up watching the Collins
and the hickses they were pushing back
against the authoritarianism that was
coming from the Christian right in
particular right they were pushing back
against that and the political landscape
has changed so much now it's kind of you
know in America you've got the Democrats
there in power now how does that affect
all that stuff
yeah well the problem is
I've reached a a saturation point where
I've lived through almost everything
like I've never none of us grew up in a
day where everything's fine now sure
it's always been the end of times on
some level and they just it just comes
from more you know sources now now
there's you can't get away from that the
world is [ __ ] dying feed I grew up
with four channels but they were a four
channels of this is the most important
election ever yeah which one wasn't in
hindsight tell me which election you
were wrong about that wasn't the most
the
censorship feminism
the 70s with this sensitive man and uh
pronouns there was a we don't we don't
want to be called Miss or misses we want
to be called Miz yeah I lived through
the 70s of [ __ ] pronoun changes and
yeah they get [ __ ] Lippy and then it
Trails off all right no one's really
gonna do that
it always blows me away like every time
I go to America and I love America I
think it's a [ __ ] great country I
think part of the reason we we [ __ ] on
it in this country is because we're
jealous if I'm being honest but like the
Fear Pawn that comes from American News
broadcasters it's it's another level
yeah
and I I that whole Roseanne quote yeah
where I go like I don't even know like
everyone in the states is angry at
everyone and there's sides but when you
go out in the world
you don't meet those people I mean
occasionally you'll see a Maga hat or
something or someone with a Prius with
too many bumper stickers but no you're
making me think that those people hate
me like the fear itself is constructed
or it's not I don't know like I have no
way to base an opinion on so I just
talked about [ __ ] and I know yeah we
were in Nashville we were getting some
chicken and there was a there was a guy
who heard that we had a foreign accent
and he said how are you enjoying America
blah blah blah and we said oh we're
actually quite enjoying it and he he
gonna soak his stuff you have no idea
how can you how can you like this
[ __ ] country's gun like that's what
he was on you know what I mean that's
weird that's weird like people here
expecting me to [ __ ] on the queen yeah
disappointed customers and this lady on
[ __ ] Twitter I should have never looked
at Twitter last night when I was really
[ __ ] high and she's like because the
guy kept yelling out talk about the
queen
and she goes in that guy's defense he
should have just talked about the queen
and that would have shut the guy up
and he's had a whole week to write
material about the Queen the queen is
not she said she should address the
elephant in the room which it's not my
room
[ __ ] matter to me on any level in any
part of my life when I did [ __ ] on
monarchy or it was a special 10 years
ago I have nothing to say just the fact
that you're angry and expect like I had
a deadline to write Queen jokes like who
the [ __ ] does the audience think they
are anymore do you think audiences have
become more entitled like yeah you do
not mine generally
because I do have a very Niche you know
chunk of the pie and no one comes in and
[ __ ] with me but yeah audiences
since comedy became like since they
could take down Comics I don't know when
that started and we don't have a lot of
crossover Comics here I don't know how
much your social media how many Comics
do you know American Comics that you
only know because of a metoo or a
canceled culture or yeah said the wrong
thing like how many American Comics do
you know that you wouldn't have known if
they hadn't got in trouble which means
sold more tickets and got more famous
yeah not a lot probably
Joe Rogan a few you know if I didn't
know sadowitz I'd know him now I mean
I've never met him but I'm aware of his
Legend but I know him now just because
of getting [ __ ] canceled in in
Edinburgh at The Fringe yeah have you
ever seen the shows no no [ __ ]
brilliant he's an incredible comic man
his stuff cannot be on TV yeah yeah
incredible and I've heard about the back
story and his personality you know I
know guys like that and yeah definitely
bucket list to see Jerry satellites oh
yeah incredible another thing that
[ __ ] kept yelling out between talk
about the queen and then you just yell
Jerry silowitz
[ __ ] high like blind in one eye high
and I can hear and you can't see [ __ ]
and it's the Hammersmith so yeah if
you're gonna take [ __ ] high chances
and Ramble On do it at the biggest place
that you ever play ever
hey Francis if you were a member of the
public would you like the opportunity to
ask incredible guests like Bill Burr
Jordan Peterson Sam Harris Adam Carolla
Brett Weinstein John Barnes Douglas
Murray Nigel farage and Lionel Shriver
your own questions you bet I would and
what do you think the best way to do
that would be uh probably stalking mate
you'd have to Corner them in the
supermarket probably brand near like the
sort of frozen food of and then just
bought questions at them before they can
escape uh not the American ones as they
have guns and you'd have to be extra
careful with the females as that's how I
got in trouble last time do you really
imagine you're gonna get Douglas Murray
near the frozen food aisle if you want
to ask our incredible guest questions
and have access to phenomenal behind the
scenes content then you have to be on
our locals that's right for only seven
dollars a month you get incredible extra
content behind the scenes footage
giveaways and also the chance to be part
of an incredible Community where you can
meet and hang out with like-minded
people you get access to our American
Vlogs as we travel across the country
interviewing Our Heroes an extra 20
minutes of our viral Sam Harris episode
as he discusses his approach to covert
we're also going to start doing
giveaways of exclusive trigonometry
merchandise like this a poster from our
Edinburgh show signed by both of us and
also a House of Lords Teddy which you
can only get in the House of Lords
signed by the one and only baroness Fox
locals also gives you access to an
incredible online community you can
share memes talk about the latest
episode or even make a new friend or
just one exactly more than both of us
have really people are now doing meetups
in their City because they love locals
in fact some people enjoy it so much
they prefer it over the show they prefer
locals to trigonometry
if I have to get them executed I'm the
one that goes to jail right go to
trigonometry.locals.com only seven
dollars a month for all that incredible
content
trigonometry.locals.com See you there
guys
it's interesting that you say that that
people have their audiences have become
more demanding because
pre-pandemic I I like I started comedy
in 2009 and I gradually noticed
audiences change and a part of it was
like is it just me like people not
everyone the vast majority were always
the same but there was always that
little pocket that just got more and
more and more vocal when they were like
upset about something or they were
demanding something yeah again we don't
we don't really have that problem in my
audiences uh
because at a certain ticket price
people aren't just shuffling in yeah oh
what's going on here oh yeah a private
party basically yeah I'm not accepting
new fans for a while I'm just gonna have
to start filling out [ __ ]
applications because I I people know at
this point what they're going to see
that's like an underground garage uh
but I do know
social media is so [ __ ] that yeah you
you will get people that but that's
where
I have to realize that my audience isn't
on [ __ ] Twitter all day the actual
asses and seats the warm bodies
have [ __ ] lives and they don't sit
around
fighting these fake fights which most of
them are uh
so
I don't I don't know how much my ACT has
changed because of
well if you have guide me somewhere that
was me it's fine I guess you you are you
were insulated from all this [ __ ] to
some extent by virtue of where you are
do you feel and do you feel like you've
had to change your act in any way are
you you're just doing you and that's it
no I I I look back and stuff I have
filmed over the years and there's a lot
of it where I go oh [ __ ] I
like there's a word or whatever that
that's completely away from the point of
what I was saying the points I was
making that they'd never hear the point
because they heard the word right so
yeah you look back and go oh God I hate
that that whole thought is lost cause I
demanded to say a word
but that's the problem isn't it Doug
it's like when somebody looks at
material that was done 15 or 20 years
ago and they're like well in 2022 this
is unacceptable and you said something
but it's not 2022 for when that bit was
filmed whenever it was yeah again I am
just straddling where I am never going
to be famous enough to be canceled
because nobody knows you'd have to if
you have to explain who the person is
then they're not canceled
so you think people people getting when
they get in canceled you mentioned Jerry
salowitz or whatever it's quite often
whatever the intention she literally got
canceled remember cancel culture is this
all-enveloping
term that doesn't quite make sense with
every situation and uh I I wish I had a
better [ __ ] phrase to recoin it but
oh literally yes it was literally
canceled where he was doing a run at The
Fringe Festival and evidently someone
said I don't [ __ ] know but I do do
know I read it when oh Jerry said it was
tickets just went up in price and
rightfully so yeah yeah do you ever find
yourself like because I love you as a
comic you're brilliant and you you tend
to go for the topics that are more
controversial the hot button topic is
there any is there is there an
attraction to you for wanting to hit
that or is it you just think [ __ ] it
well that's what's interesting to us
you know I'm I'm guessing rules still
apply that in a green room
Comics who are tired of [ __ ] pablum
yeah the first [ __ ] we talk about is you
know awful things in a green room right
yeah the same way cops are you know
firefighters Gallows humor is what they
call it yeah we have Gallows humor
naturally because we've seen every other
lighter form of comedy and let's go down
to the kick [ __ ] part or whatever
just and is it the challenge of making
something like that funny because it's
more challenging or is it just that well
you have to be interested first I guess
you have to have a point of view I mean
you can make up a point of view and I
know a million comedians are doing it
now because it sells tickets but yeah if
I don't have a belief
in what I'm saying like and there's bits
that I've tried to do I know this is
coming up
uh
uh prison just the the whole prison
institution I've never had a strong bit
about and if there is one cause I would
be behind it's a the the
unjustly uh uh incarcerated and just the
prison system the justice system itself
and
but then I just get too angry and I
don't have jokes and you can't make it
funny yeah I've never seen the angle and
that's why we have to trip tonight do
you have an academy
that's interesting
um and but you you talked to the
beginning about how you started out and
you were doing all the usual stuff that
everybody does particularly 30 years ago
all the masturbation jokes and all of
that when and how was the shift for you
when you were actually I'm gonna go in a
different did it that just evolve or was
there yeah it just evolved with the uh
like when you see character acts and you
go oh this is really funny but how where
do you go from that like if you're
talking about your life anyway and when
I was doing jerk off jokes when I was 23
that's my life if you're jerking off and
chasing [ __ ] that's all you knew so I
was honest to myself
yes when I started started growing up
and
reading things and stuff oh hey wait the
world's kind of [ __ ] up more than that
girl wouldn't blow me a karaoke
what do you read what do you read about
um
now you know I pretty much
except for Sam talent's book Running the
light which I know is coming over here
because a few people Bobby Mayer said oh
my roommate got that and I'm gonna
[ __ ] read it next it's fiction but
it's about comedy that specifically
parts of Comedy that you know oh my God
it's it's as good as Fear and Loathing
in Las Vegas and uh that gonna those
that well written uh
and it came out at the same time as my
book and I spent more time promoting
that book because I read it I never read
fiction uh it's mostly non-fiction
anything that reading another prison
book hoping I'm gonna strike a chord of
something funny in the most depressing
[ __ ] ever and is is not the challenge
challenge for you to get to make the
most depressing [ __ ] ever which is you
know the taboo subjects which is a
really tough difficult subject and make
it funny it's I don't have a challenge
anymore but
it's the best feeling when you have a
bit that you know the audience is gonna
laugh at and then think oh that was
wrong but it's too late because you
laughed because I'm right and so like I
I write as a defense attorney
that's what I I would do in a perfect
world if there was no comedy I would be
a defense attorney and
so that's behind all the [ __ ] holes
in your argument so that's really
interesting so what do you mean by that
you write like a defense attorney
just said finding the whole thing yeah
find the loopholes and okay follow the
mob yeah and then just go why is the mob
wrong here and
and then deconstruct that it's like any
material about the queen yeah it was the
the reverence for dead people like why
so let's write your queen material now
but so it's that's so interesting so you
go with the with the mob you see what
the mob believe or the group of people
that were the general consensus and then
you pick the holes in it in order to
create the comedy the the the my
favorite bits have been where okay I'm
gonna take something that would go
against the grain of the audience find a
[ __ ] loophole that makes perfect
sense like a defense attorney yeah and
then you can't handle the truth yeah
that's what I used to enjoy doing as
well it's a great it's a it's a great
feeling
um it's also that you know we when I
think of it that way the audience is
also in a place where if they do laugh
at the wrong thing how much do the we
should interview the audience sometime
how much pressure are you under to not
laugh at a specific joke because you
feel outside pressure oh if I laugh at
that I could be canceled as well as a
human being I wonder because cancel
culture me too has only affected the
famous people
well I used to remember I used to watch
people in in the audience and sometimes
people would laugh at a joke that was of
that time and then they'd look around
you could literally watch them checking
and then suddenly there was oh I'm I'm
one of the few people laughing and then
they won't laugh at the next one anymore
but there was a slow burn as you age
when you've been my age where okay yeah
we slowly didn't say that anymore like
we just kind of over the years now it's
in a [ __ ] week wait I said what and
now it's not the worst thing I can't
keep up with the kids yeah it's speeded
up yeah it is speeding up and in certain
words you it just feels like certain
words like launchy it was fine to say
this word and now you're like it's like
Bane I don't know but I feel like I'm so
old that I remember when meant a bundle
of sticks
but it did it was a different day and
age there's the Negroni yeah all right
there we go so but you don't feel under
any kind of pressure at all because
you've got your own audience or is this
still that kind of do you ever get that
kind of nagging sensation of like
is this gonna be the one time where
they're gonna get me or someone's gonna
get out right oh no last night I go this
might be the time I shouldn't have been
high on this tour and I love the fact
that I'm making progress by trying to
adapt from a liquor place of intoxicant
to a plant-based intoxicated right now
yeah but they're overlapping right and
now it's your high-end drunk and yeah
last night probably then I should have
probably dialed it back a little uh but
but you're not canceled you're still
gonna do your stuff yeah that's awesome
yeah um and that's interesting so like
so you you're starting to prefer the
plant-based intoxication because I used
to know it's just literally in the last
week
every night I go no I did one time high
on stage I loved it and I've been high
on stage every night and last night's
the first time I went yeah probably I
probably didn't remember to finish a lot
of this stories I started I might have
[ __ ] that gig up but it was just one
blemish you know otherwise Stellar week
so here's the big question what are you
gonna do next time
I guess I'm gonna have to find me a weed
guy to follow me around because it's
still illegal here in the UK what do you
think that's well what do I think about
it I just started getting high as an old
man because it's legal because they're
everywhere I that's how I did start
literally is I accidentally ate a bunch
of gummies when I was cleaning out the
[ __ ] bar before football Sunday and I
thought no this is a must be a special
back in gummies because you ate a bag of
wheat gummies I ate four you waited six
four ten milligrams what kind of state
were you in well I it was weird because
it was during when I was trying to do
sober October and that's why I was out
cleaning on a Saturday night because I
was sober and I didn't know what to do
with myself so I'm out there cleaning up
the [ __ ] bar for football Sunday when
people come over and there's a small bag
of gummies I thought they were someone
brought and I just ate them and then my
friend comes and go you didn't notice
like this the Jamaican writing on the
back and the pot leaves no I just saw
those four gummies left so I ate them
because I'm trying to [ __ ]
yeah that's how it started and had a
good football Sunday then
yeah and I've really enjoyed uh
this I I forget what we were talking
about
weed which is kind of appropriate yeah
yeah yeah yeah well he's good to see us
having an effect now it's it's it's
really been good
oh we were talking about last night but
[ __ ] last night yeah but you know what I
actually really enjoy about weed it
doesn't have the edge that alcohol has
you know alcohol like I don't know if
you get this but it it's got the
darkness to it you know what I mean yeah
the you the the next day with the
bleakness and the Darkness and sometimes
you wake up and you I have not been
hungover except for today and that was
more a weed [ __ ] almost like a k-hole
of weed today and on a day off thank God
but I have not been hungover this whole
tour I've not gotten into that place
where you're like oh [ __ ]
I can't get that sleep back every day is
gonna suck because this is gonna be on
my back so yeah I haven't had that
that's well that's great next the next
thing you're going to be joining the gym
don't don't see that happening that's
not a side effect of weed it's uh I want
to do crunches
but no that I just find that dude and
I'd love to get your opinion on this as
someone who is a drinker and enjoys
drink to me it's the worst drug
it's the worst drug surely yeah but I
got good at it
it's kind of if you were an Olympian and
at some point right before you turned
into [ __ ] Caitlyn instead of Bruce
you thought ah [ __ ] I should have done
luge yeah I get a name for myself by
doing [ __ ] discus and decathlon
whatever [ __ ] Bruce Jenner did
I wonder if he decided I want to be a
woman and I should have done the luge
what's loose I mean the point is I'm a
drunk but I appreciative
like I should have done different drugs
with my life yeah but this is the one I
got good at and it's the one I'm known
for and I'm gonna stick with the broad
that brought me so you're not gonna use
this as an opportunity if you you know
your 50s in order to explore the other
drugs you're not going to try mushroom
we're not going to see uh Doug stuff no
I've no I was a I I didn't my very fair
share of hallucinogens early on in life
when it was easy to do because you
didn't have a bunch of baggage now
and did that have an effect on your
comedy hallucinations absolutely what
was it
just the the the freedom of Mind where
you
just following thoughts to the like just
Hennigan and I drove we did uh it's your
manager yeah the Scotsman yeah I thought
he was Irish that's not going that well
oh no he hates me he hates the Irish he
hates the English and he hates the Scots
don't we all I mean that just sounds
like himself as much as he hates
everyone and he hates everyone from this
country but he has different reasons
anyway we drove five hours one of the
days we didn't take a train we we took a
five hour car service
and
he said up front because he knows I hate
music
asked the guy who's about to drive us
five hours if he could do this without
his [ __ ] stupid music on because I
like to think and I really enjoy
we didn't talk for five hours not the
driver not me and Brian for five hours
on a day trip because I like thinking
that much my [ __ ] head is always a
source of entertainment for me or a
problem whatever it is but it's always
on and I [ __ ] hate music because it
interrupts my thoughts which are what
the [ __ ] am I talking about don't you
have power to shut this down
I asked you about hallucinogens and how
they changed the comedy because yeah I
I've never taken hallucinogens but um
my understanding is it kind of opens
your mind a lot right yeah why don't you
just make a part two and then you guys
we we can all shut this down you go
[ __ ] trip I I would demand if I had
kids that at some point before
graduation they trip because you don't
[ __ ] know anything about life no
there is a magical experience when you
trip that you suddenly look around at
nature and you go oh this is [ __ ]
beautiful
and you just don't have that or maybe
not that didn't have that well no I as
I've I've gotten all over where you go
okay
being high and I I I gave a high lots of
chances when I was a teenager and
and now that I'm old high like oh this
makes music sound even better but now I
know that I know that music sucks yeah
so I feel like I'm being tricked by the
drug okay the Marrakesh Express this
song sucks and I'm singing it out loud
and I'm embarrassing myself because I'm
new to the drug
the I I had that experience with ecstasy
I'm like I used to listen to the
electronic music you know like the whole
rage scene dancing you're like this
music sounds [ __ ] When You're Sober yeah
if you need to take a pill to make the
music sound good that's a problem yeah
then just shut off the [ __ ] music and
if you can't entertain yourself
yeah it's a good point so what do you
think like when you go on those car
Journeys you talk about your thoughts
what do you think about is it the comedy
that you're trying to write is it a bit
is it we're trying to recreate a dream
you had last night another benefit to
the weed sleep so good yeah and and my
[ __ ] dreams are the best eyes and I I
try to manipulate my dreams and
and they're they're boring to talk about
it's you really have to be an insular
person
enjoy your dreams Doug I think I hate
myself I'm watching my podcast
in my head I'm watching what you're
watching and I'm like just shut the [ __ ]
up dude what would you ask you if you
were doing this podcast right now
I don't know that troll me
every time someone trolls you like ah I
would if if you could get paid to be a
troll I was way better at trolling
upsetting pranking people than I was
ever as a comedian and if there was a
way to do I know it's awful and wrong
and that's why school shootings happen
everything about it is wrong but I was
so [ __ ] good at it and now you go ah
why would I do that to someone
yeah or you could do it I mean if you
want to monetize trolling you start a
YouTube show called trigonometry
yeah you guys get to teach me about
monetizing
who's your uh who's your sponsors uh
well we don't know who's going to be in
this episode but yeah but the manscaped
yeah vpns and people like that yeah yeah
so use promo code Stanhope
all of their
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website because if you do then
easy DNS is a company for you easy DNS
is the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be cancel culture D
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows about that
so will you in a second easy DNS have
Rock Solid Network infrastructure and
fantastic customer support they're in
your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you know about that move your
domains and websites over to easy DNS
right now all you've got to do is go to
easydns.com forward slash triggered
that's easydns.com forward slash
triggered use our promo code which is
also triggered and get 50 off the
initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy which tells
you you everything you need to know
about technology privacy and censorship
for instance is a comic Doug uh Dice
Clay was the one that got me to actually
do
stand up I I would repeat his first
album everyone my age knew every word of
that
[ __ ] this you said but that's just
such a good dick I don't
it was
perfect at the time and we're kind of at
that time again everything being
cyclical Dice Clay Sam Kinison all the
Outlaws of Comedy [ __ ] [ __ ] they
came off the heels of 10 years of Jerry
Seinfeld and Paul Reiser and Ellen
Degeneres and watch up with airplane
food and this was the refreshing break
from was Dice Clay [ __ ] you and Sam can
I said oh yeah it's because you had
[ __ ] 10 years of really boring
[ __ ] benign comedy and that spurred
that so when you [ __ ] about canceled
culture just think of it as a business
deal like oh okay now we can maybe have
maybe a genres of Comedy rather than
Comedy Club they don't have music Club
they have different sub genres and maybe
okay
awoke comedy night and it's a safe space
there's nothing wrong with that like the
[ __ ] simpletons that yell out talk
about the queen that try to give you
comedy advice
well why this is [ __ ] woke comedy
well you should be comedy should be
about everything no comedy should be
[ __ ]
put in a
so you don't walk into comedies that you
hate it shouldn't be just labeled comedy
well we have that uh there's a there is
a woke comedy night in the UK yeah we
also have a comedy Unleashed in London
which is like say whatever you want to
make whatever jokes you want it's pretty
limiting when you look at the genres of
music which is symphony and Mumble rap
and EDM and [ __ ] this and that there's a
million and we have woken love [ __ ] you
yeah which is splitting people into
[ __ ] sides yet again and party lines
and it all I agree with you because uh I
was never a fan of the work stuff I was
by the way never a fan of the overly
offensive stuff either I was sort of
leaning towards that but not really
doing that but I never thought comedy
should be like banned or whatever I just
I don't enjoy it other people enjoy it
let them go and see you that's what
again when the audience thinks they're
part of the [ __ ] conversation like
they know what you do beat that lady on
Twitter that I should have never looked
at Twitter
he should have just
what do you think of social media
sorry oh no I can't even remember if I
said this on the podcast or before when
we were talking but the lady that was
you did yeah you did yeah you mentioned
social media a lot and you talked about
how people are divided online but
actually when you go out into the real
world most people aren't so do you think
that is a product of social media social
media has made it that way the people
are screaming it's made me that way
because again it's all your
your own perception of the world and how
you craft that
yeah if you sit on social media and
you're not even aware that oh this is
not real life
I at least am aware enough okay that's
not real life but it still sucks in
maybe people I have no idea you'd have
to ask everybody their goddamn opinion
and that's it isn't it that we just go
on this this device we get sucked in and
then we go oh this is someone's opinion
and you're like probably isn't they
probably just wrote that they didn't
even think about it but at the same time
I go to a bar and I see a bunch of
people talking that probably work
together in an office a situation have
never really been in in my life and
they're communicating
and you go all right there every one of
those people's lives is different than
my perception of even my own life and
there's no consensus
this is the problem with the high part
is you just start breaking [ __ ] down
like you're just thinking and you go oh
I'm on a four camera shoot right now and
I'm just sitting here doing what I'd be
doing in my head don't we have questions
from the audience why don't we go to the
[ __ ] Doug I am feeling High just sitting
next to you right yeah and I was sober
when I walked in there so but you guys
almost killed your Waters yeah we did
almost kill the waters absolutely
there's one question so you had the Dice
Clay were you a Hicks fan Bill Hicks not
till later on I had to be hipped to
someone who knew Hicks yeah uh so yeah
later on and yeah and joy the Hicks yeah
but it was not yeah it was this stupid
[ __ ] that got me into comedy do you
watch Comedy who's your favorite no no
you don't [ __ ] no yeah
um my favorite of all time is David tell
hands down
and it's weird to be at an age where you
can pull a superlative when someone says
what's your favorite movie or song I
don't know I'm [ __ ] old I had a
million favorite songs and best friends
but best comic uh yeah hands down a tell
Mitch Hedberg uh uh Second Place well
you're gonna enjoy Jerry's sideowitz
whenever you see him in that case yeah
but anyway man we do have uh questions
from the audience but before we do we
always answer the same question uh which
is complete free hit which is what is
the one thing that we're not talking
about that you think we really should be
but I think I addressed that earlier the
prison system yeah tell us more about
that why do you feel so strongly about
it it it it it hurts everyone it's one
of those things I know
all right this [ __ ] comedy brain I
knew I know if I could attack that bit
from a conservative angle that makes
conservatives Mega people feel a little
bit emasculated for like why would you
allow this go like pro-anti-government
why would we because Prison just makes
communities worse it makes everything
worse there's nothing rehabilitative in
it there's everything about it sucks
that's the problem it's like if I say
tell me uh one song you want me to play
right now and you go well I'm [ __ ] an
adult I've heard a million song like
what's the problem with prison [ __ ]
everything and it makes Society worse
and what and you you you're proud to pay
for it
do you think we shouldn't have prisons
at all
there's going to be a better idea uh
like there's [ __ ] writers out of work
that are comedy writers I don't know if
I had the idea I'd quit comedy if I
could go full bore on this is a better
idea almost everything
and I don't know if I I grew up thinking
eventually I'm gonna go to jail and get
diabetes because that was those were
threats you're gonna keep eating candy
you're gonna [ __ ] get diabetes Well
this person just in case you one day or
nothing yeah with diabetes
in trouble you're gonna wind up in jail
you keep eating candy you're gonna
[ __ ] wind up with diabetes yeah yeah
now I'm terrified of the [ __ ] wrongly
accused Innocence Project if I die on
this tour which every time I'm in the UK
I know I'm gonna die on this loneliest
[ __ ] planet horrible place
but Innocence Project that's where you
send your uh donations all right well
you've just had an introduction to the
wonderful mind of Doug Stanhope Doug
you're on tour at the moment you're
going to be doing stuff in in Las Vegas
I think yeah it's it's on your website
it's all on your website thanks so much
for joining us we're going to ask you a
couple of questions from our supporters
thanks for watching oh well we've we're
going to patreon oh yeah good I've seen
some [ __ ] good [ __ ] hey non-patreon
people I saved the good [ __ ] for go
ahead donate donate now no other guest
has done that yeah that's Doug is great
yeah absolutely join our locals we'll
see there with a couple of your
questions for Doug uh see you there
thanks for watching and we'll see you
very soon we normally end it on a more
professional night oh my God this [ __ ]
build but what's gonna happen next
exactly no one knows it it's gonna be on
locals [ __ ] check it out
this is a question from icky Ike who
says how hard is it for you to perform
sober